why did Paul McCartney write Let It Be I
had a dream it was in the years when
we're probably overdoing everything
drinking and getting staying out too
late and getting crazy so I was a bit
sort of exhausted and I went to bed
anyway I had a dream and my mother who
died probably about 10 years previously
was in the dream she came to me in the
Dream It's a magic moment because you're
actually there with your mother so she
seemed to know that I was a bit stressed
out and she said don't worry it's going
to be fine
Let It Be
and I thought wow wow and just felt
really great that my mother had given me
that advice and woke up and was just
remembering the dream and I thought what
did she say I said Let It Be and so I
thought that was a great idea for a song
so I went to the piano and wrote it